Hey, what's up guys?
I am Grant Thompson - "The King of Random"
Hey man I am Brian Brushwood from the Modern Rogue.
And internet we are presenting a new challenge to you today -
Can you make butter faster than you can make toast?
Yeah have you heard of the cinnamon challenge, the ice bucket challenge?
Nothing compared to this: Making butter faster than making toast, that's not possible!
This is a new challenge
We haven't even tried ourselves, so we went down to the store.
We got some heavy whipping cream.
Come check this out this cream has not been opened yet. You can see me pull the seal
The only thing that we've done different with this cream is we've let it sit out for about uh
Three hours. Now how long does it take to make toast a couple of minutes? Yeah, give or take. So
ideally we should be able to make butter within 20 to 40 seconds, okay, all right
So we need something to pour the water into as well right
Right, so we're gonna dump out our water
I got a little container over here that we can dump our water into
Okay, all right. Pieces a toast, so this is the idea we're using water bottles today
And this is a shout-out to my friend Dan Rojas from the channel Green Power Science
His theory was that some of the ribbing on the sides of the water bottle would help assist in the churning of the butter
So our goal is to make this as quickly as possible. We're using water bottles
There's a good chance you have water bottles at home today as well
So these are the rules: You put in your piece of toast and as soon as you press play
We're going to pour in the cream
Put on the lids and shake this thing and see if we can turn butter and get it ready before the toast pops up
Okay, we're not actually sure if this is gonna work or not, but we're gonna do it here live for you first try
Uncut no jump cuts. Here we go here
We go. All right so I even got a stopwatch over here on my phone. Alright give it a start
Callahan so we're Gonna go in three two one begin start the toast they got how much- how full do I go let's go
That's good enough right there, [okay], and go ahead you put your lid on okay, whoa?
Yup here we go and shake shake shake shake shake. We're gonna make a mess cause this is spilled everywhere
Look at that. That's creamy. [all] right, [shoot] this sucks. [I] need a cloth
*I need a new cloth!*
Haha, mommy. I made a mess. What should I be feeling as I'm doing okay? So it starts off as a liquid and
Then after hopefully a few seconds. It's gonna turn into whipped cream
Nobody close your eyes while we are doing this.
Oh man!
It should go into whipped cream [its]
Mine goes faster than this what kind of cream is this I don't know
I don't know! I got the heavy whipping cream
Okay, so actually mine's clumping up already. It's turning into whipping whipped cream, and you want to just go a little bit faster
Get real close to toasties. [it'll] close to go harder. Go faster
[I] can feel it you're gonna feel that thing clumping around and then it's gonna break back into a liquid
Come on
Oh, no, it's frothy. It's frothy. I got froth keep on
It's okay. It's like nothing and it goes back to a liquid at some point.
It's so hard right now (get ur mind out of the gutter)
The toast is coming soon
It's looking kinda toasty
Okay, mines all clumped. Just feels like it's full. Yeah, it is foamy. You got to break it. Yeah break that food bring it
Those are the G-forces that make it happen?
Or the turbulence or what?
I think so. I don't know what it is
Teamwork!
oh
woo
It just feels like I'm shaking styrofoam. Yes, it just it's like a full bottle of... whoo
Maybe we should've dumped us. Yeah
Yeah, maybe we did too much, so it doesn't start to it start to feel like that only quitting see look at this
It's actually
Kind of looks like butter. (XD) Oh you have it. I wonder if it was too warm
Is that is that bad? What temperature? Do you want to do?
I'm not sure
So I mean like we were talking [about] it being room temperature. We made sure to set the upstairs to 76 degrees
Supposed to be faster than this stuff. Oh
Toast is coming soon! Oh, it's starting to toast!
You wanna make it dark toast?
Don't know man. I think I got butter, but it's like it's weird. It's like oh look at that!
My God you have butter you've got butter, but the weird thing is is like. I can't believe it's not butter. Whoah!. it's going everywhere
We did it! We did it!
We [made] butter let's spread the butter. Yeah, holy holy crap of that is he well
Yes
All right here now if you don't mind me king of random [would] you toast to me?
We'd like to make a toast to all of you out [there]
Hopefully have better success to win tell us how you do with the toasted butter challenge cool hMM
bigger than the Cinnamon challenge [the] ice bucket [challenge]
It's really interesting about this is like the buttermilk is actually mixed in with the butter
Oh good wow we made butter faster than we made toast that's actually incredible and then the whole time
I was thinking it wasn't gonna work because it was all clumped up in there, and it wasn't moving mmM
Does he taste like whipped cream at all it is butters. Just lighter creamier fluffy. It's almost like Margarine right? Yeah, oh
Amazing so I haven't seen this happen before but instead of separating into butter and cream or buttermilk it actually like
conglomerated into some kind of softer into pure girlishness is what it did we want to see you do this so make a video of
You shaking cream into butter [mist] your videos on the internet?
Hashtag butter toast challenge the butter Toast Challenge also make sure to check out the Modern Road
We're on a quest to become the ultimate there. [that's] brian
He is the Modern Road [humanists] partner to do all kinds of crazy things so go check him out
I'll put the links in the description and for you guys so much fun hanging out today. Go make yourself a snack
You know the funny thing is we probably were at this stage in like the first 30 seconds
Yeah, but we're have an eye for quality. That's why we kept going
you